buonasera grazie sempre oggi sparsi gli
occhiali durante intenditor importanti
quando ero piccolo i miei genitori
volevano che facessi il medico non
avevano torto
la medicina è importante utile serve a
guarire le persone a salvare le vite i
miei nonni invece avrebbero preferito
vedermi ingegnere e nemmeno questa una
cattiva idea perché anche l'ingegneria e
utile serve per esempio a far star a
piedi gli edifici come quello in cui ci
troviamo ora ma si sa ogni famiglia alla
sua pecora nera ed è per questo che io
ho studiato astronomia l'astronomia non
salva vite non fa stare in piedi palati
perché allora la studiamo che cosa ha da
darci l'astronomia possiamo dare tante
risposte a questa domanda possiamo dire
per esempio che accresce la conoscenza
di ciò che intorno a noi un fine che già
di per sé a nobilissimi oppure possiamo
dire che le sue ricadute tecnologiche
migliorano profondamente la vita di
tutti noi
argomento che meriterebbe senz'altro un
talk a parte
oppure possiamo dire la verità e cioè
che studiamo astronomia principalmente
perché immagini come questa sono
veramente permette belle sono belle da
togliere il fiato
ma io penso che l'astronomia meriti di
essere studiata anche perché ha qualcosa
da insegnarci e quello questo di bello
secondo me questo non aspetto forse un
po trascurato di questa disciplina
un po come dire lasciato al lettore
però credo che meriti di essere prese
sul serio
e essere detto esplicitamente noi esseri
umani abbiamo sempre avuto il bisogno di
intentare delle storie e di raccontarci
le per darci un po il senso di chi siamo
e qual è il nostro posto nel mondo
gli antichi greci per esempio si
raccontavano che il cosmo fosse nato da
il caos primordiale gli assiro
babilonesi dicevano che invece è
l'universo era nato da un nuovo cosmico
il libro più venduto al mondo se ci
pensate è un tentativo particolarmente
ben riuscito di raccontare la nostra
storia in un modo che ci faccia sentire
parte integrante di un tutt'uno che è
molto molto più grande di noi
ecco io credo che l'astronomia cda un
nuovo modo di raccontare questa storia
in modo diverso basato su un approccio
scientifico
se fossimo vissuti per esempio all'epoca
di dante avremmo creduto che l'universo
fosse fatto più o meno così invece oggi
sappiamo che è più simile a questo avere
questa consapevolezza non può non
restituirci un senso differente d qual è
il nostro posto in mezzo a tutto questo
cosa facciamo noi qui dentro
in definitiva di chi siamo è appunto
quello che vorrei fare questa sera con
voi è tentare di raccontare la nostra
storia non per come possiamo
inventarsela ma per come abbiamo potuto
capirla dall'astrofisica dell'ultimo
secolo e questa storia ridotta
all'essenziale potrebbe suonare più o
meno così
in principio era la forza non troppo
forza ma qualcosa del genere una forza
unificata che si separò spontaneamente
nelle quattro interazioni fondamentali
che oggi conosciamo gravità
elettromagnetismo nucleare debole
nucleare forte poi comparvero le
particelle su cui queste forze potevano
agire
la prima a nascere full quark quando
l'universo aveva appena un millesimo di
miliardesimo di secondo come l'acqua
diventa ghiaccio sotto una certa
temperatura
allo stesso modo man mano che l'universo
si espande va e si raffreddava i quark
condensa rono in protoni e neutroni
questo succedeva un milionesimo di
secondo dopo il big bang
poi comparvero gli elettroni e
naturalmente a tutte le altre particelle
380.000 anni dopo
l'universo era abbastanza freddo per
permettere a protoni ed elettroni
riunirsi e mettere al mondo gli atomi
allora l'universo divenne trasparente e
fu fatta la luce
all'epoca l'universo aveva una
temperatura di circa 3 mila gradi e
questo significa che la prima luce del
cosmo era letteralmente di questo colore
l'universo era alla di luce arancione se
noi ci fossimo stati avremmo visto
questo a perdita d'occhio e che ne è
stato degli atomi gli atomi appena
formati non vennero più disturbati dalle
altre forze e cominciarono a seguire
soltanto la gravità e a farsi guidare
l'uno verso l'altro dalla sua spinta
gentile dopo poche centinaia di milioni
di anni
le prime nubi di gas si erano ormai
contratte e compresse sempre più
nacquero così le stelle nel cuore di
queste ben se sfere le temperature erano
tali da innescare violente reazioni di
fusione tra i protoni reazioni che
liberano energia luminosa le stelle
quindi si accesero
nuovo nell'universo fu fatta la luce
grazie alle reazioni termonucleari le
stelle più massicce generarono nel loro
ventre gli atomi pesanti il carbonio
azoto ossigeno al ferro via dicendo
questi atomi poi vennero sparpagliati
per il cosmo nell'istante della morte
delle loro stelle madri e andarono poi a
formare altre stelle e altri pianeti tra
cui in particolare questo che penso
riconosciate gli atomi hanno poi
continuato a dirsi a incastrarsi a
combinarsi insieme come tanti mattoncini
fino a creare anche noi
ora che cosa ci insegna questa storia
che siamo insignificanti che siamo
speciali siano insignificanti
non c'è dubbio su questo qui potete
vedere una simulazione effettuata al
computer del nostro universo è larga
cinque miliardi di anni luce
il 70 per cento del contenuto
dell'universo qui non lo potete nemmeno
vedere perché non è nemmeno materia
energia
gli astronomi la chiamano energia oscura
ed è responsabile dell'espansione
accelerata dell'universo che abbiamo
osservato appena una ventina d'anni fa
quindi il costo in realtà contiene molta
più energia che materia paradossalmente
alla materia che hanno invece sembra
così familiare a essere strana nel cosmo
e non è finita qui perché la 85 per
cento della materia che qui vedete in
viola non è nemmeno la materia ordinaria
quella che tutti conosciamo quella per
intenderci fatta di protoni neutroni
elettroni è una forma di materia
misteriosa è ancora sconosciuta che gli
astronomi chiamano materia oscura
ma trascura non c'entra niente con
energia oscura e che gli astronomi non
sanno vari nomi alle cose e non sono
bravi è una forma di materia che
sappiamo che c'è ma non a me ma non
abbiamo ancora osservato non siamo
riusciti mai osservata perché non
interagisce con la materia ordinaria se
non tramite la gravità quindi
ironicamente e la materia che noi
chiamiamo ordinaria essere strana nel
coso e della materia ordinaria
nell'universo quella che vedete in
giallo
in realtà solo un 10 per cento è sotto
forma di atomi il resto è o in forma di
plasma cioè stelle oppure materia
ionizzata dalla luce delle stelle quindi
sono gli atomi essere strani
nell'universo facendo i conti risulta
che gli atomi costituiscono appena lo
0,3 per cento del contenuto totale
dell'universo ma gli atomi siamo noi
siamo fatti diano noi siamo lo 0 3 per
cento dell'universo
allora chiedo di nuovo siamo
significanti o siamo speciali siano
insignificanti
anche perché siamo minuscoli questa
alcuni di voi l'avranno già vista è
un'immagine realizzata dal telescopio
spaziale hubble e osservando una regione
di cielo piccolissima estesa quanto un
granello di sabbia posto alla distanza
di un braccio dai nostri occhi in questa
regione di cielo piccolissima hubble ha
trovato qualcosa come 10 mila galassie
ciascuna con dentro miliardi e miliardi
di stelle ed è solo un granello di
sabbia quindi immaginate quante ganassi
ci sono nell'intero universo osservabile
centinaia di miliardi
si calcola per un totale di almeno
almeno 10.000 miliardi di miliardi di
stelle
e ognuno ha i suoi pianeti attorno noi
siamo piccoli siamo piccolissimi e
nonostante tutte queste galassie
l'universo è praticamente vuoto perché è
vero c'è tanta roba dentro ma è così
grande che la sua densità media è in
realtà bassissima una particella per
metro cubo o poco più di nuovo siamo
insignificanti
noi siamo speciali l'astronomia ci
insegna che alla fine della fiera noi
umani siamo esseri minuscoli
estremamente fragili e completamente
soli di fronte a un vuoto
inimmaginabilmente vasto ma ci insegna
anche che siamo parte di un tutt'uno
come dice il libro più venduto al mondo
siamo parte di un tutt'uno molto più
grande di noi che è l'universo stesso
perché ognuno di noi ha reso il tatto
del perenne riciclo di protoni nel cosmo
i protoni nel nostro corpo ce ne sono
circa 10 alla 28 10 miliardi di miliardi
di miliardi protoni che prima di far
parte di noi hanno fatto parte di chissà
quanti altri esseri umani animali
vegetali e prima ancora erano parte del
pianeta e prima ancora della nube di gas
da cui 4 miliardi e mezzo di anni fa si
formò il sistema solare e prima ancora
erano parte di ater stelle morte prima
che nascesse il sole
se prendete un protone del vostro
mignolo sinistro protone nel vostro
mignolo destro è probabile che
provengono da due stelle diverse stelle
che non hanno nemmeno un nome perché non
esistono più e prima ancora quei protoni
erano in altre stelle ancora e prima
ancora quando le galassie non si erano
ancora formate vivevano soli un universo
completamente buio
molti dei protoni nel nostro corpo
sono in giro dal primo milionesimo di
secondo di vita dell'universo hanno
letteralmente visto dipanarsi né
miliardi di anni l'intera trama del film
cosmico sono stati nebulose stelle
supernove come et e alberi cani e ora
sono nomi in questo momento nel nostro
corpo ci sono atomi che sono appartenuti
a shakespeare gengis khan a mozart
se avete un eroe un personaggio storico
a cui vi sentite particolarmente legati
beh sappiate che statisticamente
parlando in questo momento nel vostro
corpo ci sono circa 1 miliardo di attimi
che sono appartenuti a quella persona è
la persona che un giorno per prima
sbarcherà su un altro pianeta o che
magari premere il pulsante che spazzerà
via il nostro avrà dentro un miliardo di
atom che ora sono vostri perché alla
fine siamo tutti fatti degli stessi
identici atomi che girano per il cosmo
da 13 a 8 miliardi di anni
gli atomi l'abbiamo visto sono 103 per
cento dell'universo noi non siamo che
una minuscola frazione di questa già
piccola percentuale siamo grumi di atomi
che momentaneamente per un tempo
brevissimo si sono organizzati in un
certo modo
prima di disperdersi e tornare a fare
quello che hanno sempre fatto cioè
essere una minuscola ma integrante parte
dell'universo siamo insignificanti sì ma
siamo anche speciali perché siamo
consapevoli di tutto questo e perché
possiamo far fronte comune siamo unirci
per far fronte al vuoto immenso che ci
circonda all'inizio della vita nel
dell'universo nei suoi primi istanti una
forza attrattiva quella nucleare a
partire dai quark ha generato i nuclei
atomici e a partire dai nuclei atomici
un'altra forza attrattiva quella
elettromagnetica ha generato gli atomi e
a partire dagli atomi una terza forza
attrattiva quella gravitazionale ha
generato le stelle dei pianeti su questo
pianeta ci siamo noi e seguendo la
stessa logica a me piace pensare che un
altra forza attrattiva che però non sta
nei libri di fisica sia in grado di
generare tutto ciò che di buono può
venire dalla nostra specie questo ha
insegnato a me l'astronomia forse là
fuori c'è una persona che vi piace più
di tutte le altre
o forse magari è proprio in questa sala
forse un protone della vostra pelle si
trovava proprio accanto un protone della
sua pelle quando l'universo era non più
grande di un acido di un acino d'uva
forse forse quei due protoni sono stati
separati per 13 a 8 miliardi di anni per
incontrarsi la prima volta che vi siete
abbracciati grazie
[Applauso]